[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend ihnen allen schön dass sie
dabei sind wie auch norbert könig für
den sport ja guten abend volles programm
und das sind die nachrichten themen von
heute
preise explosion auch beim strom um
verbraucher und unternehmer zu entlasten
will die regierung den strommarkt
reformieren
angst vor bürgerkrieg in libyen kämpfen
rivalisierende milizen dutzende menschen
sterben
land unter in pakistan verheerende
regenfälle machen millionen menschen
obdachlos mehr als 1000 kommen in den
fluten ums leben
[Musik]
dass russland immer weniger gas nach
deutschland liefert das treibt nicht nur
die preise für gas steil nach oben
sondern leider auch automatisch die für
strom weil der strompreis an den
gaspreis gekoppelt ist
das ist der höhenflug des strompreises
der vergangenen wochen am freitag
kostete eine megawattstunde 995 euro
über 1000 prozent mehr als vor einem
jahr betreibern von windrädern
solaranlagen und kohlekraftwerken
beschert das üppige gewinne den
stromkunden dagegen drohen massive
tariferhöhungen deswegen will die
bundesregierung jetzt den strom vom
gaspreis entkoppeln britta buchholz
das verbot der außenbeleuchtung
öffentlicher gebäude es gilt bereits
doch es wird bei den preisen wenig
helfen deutschland schlittert in die
neue krise nach gas jetzt auch strom der
fdp finanzminister fordert deshalb die
gewinne steigen zu lasten der
verbraucher milliarde um milliarden die
bundesregierung muss sich mit größter
dringlichkeit den strompreisen widmet
das problem bislang ist der strompreis
an den gaspreis gekoppelt spricht steigt
der gaspreis steigt automatisch der
strompreis wirtschaftsminister habeck
will dies ändern nur das dürfte nicht so
leicht sein eine entkopplung ist derzeit
nicht machbar und auch nicht angebracht
weil da müsste man den europäischen
strommarkt reformieren das dauert lange
er muss es im moment kurzfristig darum
gehen dass wir den strommarkt entlasten
doch der ausbau der erneuerbaren hakte
in bayern liegt der verlangsamte bau
neuer stromtrassen auch am widerstand
der csu dies räumt der ministerpräsident
im zdf sommerinterview das neue problem
führt zu einer alten debatte ja oder
nein zu atom strom
die drei laufenden kraftwerke in
deutschland ab ständig geplant dann
müssen sie strom für zehn millionen
haushalte ersetzen zehnfache
preissteigerung bei strom wir werden
erleben dass viele normalverdiener echte
probleme habe das alles zu finanzieren
das spannende ist ja dass die leute die
das jetzt massiv einfordern gleichzeitig
sagen vier jahre fünf jahre länger oder
komplett neu bauen das ist eine
komplette phantomdebatte und wenn markus
söder der selber mal umweltminister war
wir sind wie alle richtungen dreht dann
streute den leuten sein
während die politik diskutiert steigen
die preise weiter die ampel schlittert
in die neue krise nach gas jetzt strom
außenministerin baerbock hat der ukraine
lange unterstützung zugesichert wenn
nötig der bild am sonntag sagte sie der
krieg könnte jahre dauern auch im
nächsten sommer müsse man womöglich
schwere waffen liefern in der ukraine
bleibt die lage am atomkraftwerk sapori
sehr angespannt nach russischen und
ukrainischen angaben gibt es bereits
schäden an der anlage
radioaktive strahlung sei aber nicht
ausgetreten
in libyen wächst die sorge dass der
bürgerkrieg wieder aufflammt bei
gefechten in der hauptstadt tripolis
starben in den vergangenen tagen
mindestens 32 menschen
seit jahren ist das land gespalten die
umgebung um tripolis kontrolliert
premierminister data er wird von der uno
anerkannt sein gegner sitzt im
abgespaltenen osten der frühere
innenminister was aber auch er
beansprucht die macht im ganzen land
goliath berichtet
tripolis am morgen ausgebrannte autos
beschossene krankenhäuser und moscheen
die kämpfe haben in dicht besiedelten
gegenden im zentrum stattgefunden eine
solche welle der gewalt hat der tripolis
seit zwei jahren nicht mehr erlebt
sie zeigt dass rivalisierende milizen
weiter erstarken und über die machthaber
im land entscheiden
die leidtragenden zivilisten
krankenwagen konnten viele einwohner
nicht erreichen
eigentlich hätte libyen im vergangenen
dezember eine neue regierung gewählt
aber statt wahlen hat das land jetzt
zwei parallele regierungen hinter beiden
stehen milizen
radfahrer vom parlament im ostteil des
landes zum übergangs premier minister
ernannt fordert die international
anerkannte regierung in tripolis heraus
deren premier abdel hamid weber gestern
abend die ihm loyalen kämpfer den
angriffen baschar us stand gehalten zu
haben
waffen sind jetzt lauter als jede stimme
in libyen das heißt es wird keine
stabilität geben ich sehe keinerlei
anzeichen für eine einigung um ernsthaft
eine neue regierung zu erreichen
gelingt es den vereinten nationen nicht
beide seiten auf einen wahltermin zu
verpflichten könnte libyen neue unruhe
neben
nach pakistan dort zeigt sich der
klimawandel besonders drastisch durch
die folgen des monsunregens kamen
alleine in den vergangenen 24 stunden
mindestens 100 menschen ums leben seit
juni mehr als 1000 insgesamt sind mehr
als 33 millionen menschen betroffen
normen odenthal
wer hier überleben will braucht
wagemutige retter auf einem winzigen
flecken erde geht der helikopter runter
holt zwei menschen raus die sonst wohl
keine chance mehr hätten es geht um
leben und tod für so viele in pakistan
rettung in letzter minute mehr als 1000
haben es nicht geschafft und jeden tag
werden es mehr die braunen fluten ziehen
durchs ganze land der monsun wird jedes
jahr sehnsüchtig erwartet weil er
endlich regen bringt nur dieses jahr
bringt er viel zu viel das ausmaß ist
furchterregend was ist da nur über sie
gekommen und was ist ihnen noch
geblieben
wir schicken das wasser raus so gut wir
können um noch irgendwas zu retten
irgendwas das noch nicht kaputt ist aber
da ist nichts sie hatten nie viel und
auch davon ist fast alles verloren die
regierung hat den notstand ausgerufen
auch um schneller helfen zu können aber
hilfe fehlt doch weiter fast überall
die wassermassen kamen so schnell ich
war auf dem feld konnte mich in
sicherheit bringen und mein viel einige
meiner kinder waren noch zu hause sie
sitzen auf dem dach unseres hauses ich
muss zurück und
es soll weiter regnen heißt es keine
guten aussichten in pakistan wo ihnen
das wasser ohnehin schon buchstäblich
bis zum hals steht
zurück nach deutschland im rhein main
gebiet waren heute zwei autobahnen
gesperrt für eine klimaschutz demo
tausende waren aufs fahrrad gestiegen um
für eine verkehrswende in hessen zu
werben sie fuhren von frankfurt nach
wiesbaden mit dabei hatten sie
unterschriften für ein volksbegehren
ziel mehr investitionen in radwege und
den öffentlichen nahverkehr
und jetzt noch ein tisch für
deutschlands höchste eisenbahnbrücke die
es nämlich 125 jahre alt geworden und
wurde entsprechend gefeiert die
müngstener brücke zwischen remscheid und
solingen ist 107 meter hoch und 465
meter lang gebaut zum einhundertsten
geburtstag von kaiser wilhelm dem ersten
galt sie damals als deutschlands antwort
auf den pariser eiffelturm
und wer schwindelfrei ist
kann auch auf klettern
auf der höhe sind auch die basketballer
nova tolles spiel und damit beste
werbung für die bevorstehende
europameisterschaft heute ging es noch
um punkte für die wm qualifikation die
holt das deutsche team mit einem klaren
sieg gegen den aktuellen europameister
slowenien und bleibt gruppen-erster im
letzten viertel herrscht bereits ein
lächeln über das gesicht von kapitän
dennis schröder so einfach hat sich das
deutsche team die sache gegen slowenien
mit nba-superstar luca don't judge
wirklich nicht vorgestellt am ende sitzt
ein dreier nach dem anderen 90 zu 71 das
klare ergebnis dass viel selbstvertrauen
für die em gibt die am donnerstag in
köln gegen frankreich beginnt
erster sieg für deutschlands volleyball
team der männer bei der wm in slowenien
und polen nach der klaren
auftaktniederlage gegen frankreich
gelingt heute ein ebenso deutlicher 13 0
erfolg gegen kamerun der letzte
gruppengegner in ljubljana ist co
gastgeber slowenien
von platz 14 gestartet am ende mal
wieder ganz oben formel 1 weltmeister
max verstappen gewinnt den großen preis
von belgien
tausende fans aus den niederlanden
bejubelten spa frauke schockieren driver
of the day verstappen gewinnt mit knapp
18 sekunden vorsprung auf seinen
teamkollegen sergio perez in der
gesamtwertung sind es jetzt 93 punkte
sebastian vettel wird achter
der gesamtsieger der deutschland tour
für radprofis heißt er denn jetzt mit
platz fünf auf der letzten etappe von
schiltach nach stuttgart das ziel
erreicht der spanier periode im sprint
als erster und wird gesamtzweiter
zimmermann holt heute platz drei und
insgesamt rang vier als bester deutscher
und zwei zweite plätze für denise
herrmann und roman re ist zum abschluss
der sommerbiathlon wm in ruhpolding
denise herrmann muss sich im massenstart
rennen nach einem fehlschuss nur der
italienerin dorothea wierer geschlagen
geben rees verliert in der schlussrunde
die führung noch an den schweden
sebastian samuelsson der insgesamt drei
medaillen mit gericht
das war nicht wenig sport mit der
rangliste bei der deutschland-tour noch
mal erklären schreibe ich ja auch toll
dankeschön für das wetter im norden
teils dicht bewölkt und vereinzelt etwas
regen nach süden hin freundliche
mischung aus sonne und wolken
höchstwerte 19 bis 29 grad und in den
nächsten tagen gibt es an der ostsee
einzelne schauer im süden gewitter meist
aber trocken bei ähnlichen temperaturen
im heute journal um viertel vor zehn
spricht marietta slomka mit
wirtschaftsminister habeck hier
übernimmt morgen mitri sirin und wir
sagen tschüss wünschen ihnen einen guten
start in die neue woche und empfehlen
jetzt das zdf sommerinterview mit
csu-chef söder